- This is my favorite thing.
It's like the movie with Matt Damon,
like, We Bought A Zoo.
Y'all live in a zoo.
- It's so true.
- Yes, exactly.
- We live right in the
middle of Australia Zoo
and we are very, very lucky.
Australia Zoo is the most spectacular
hands-on zoological facility in the world.
People describe it as
a resort for wildlife
because we love our animals so much.
They're part of our family.
- I went, I died.
- Oh, that's so lovely, that's right!
- I remember that.
- Thank you so much, love!
- I was like, "Hello, giraffe."
- Yes, exactly.
You've gotta come back!
- Yes!
- Sometimes we put the carrot
in our mouth and they lick
the carrot out of our mouth.
- It's incredible.
- It's the coolest experience.
- It's very slobbery, guys.
- [Bindi] It takes off all your makeup!
- I love animals.
I don't know if I wanna
make out with them.
- So, you've been licked by a giraffe.
- I would love to be licked, oh!
(laughs)
- [Kristen] I mean, I don't
mean that in a bad way!
- Yeah, yeah!
- [Bindi] We're with you!
- [Kristen] I don't mean it in a bad way!
- We are with you! A hundred percent!
- It's like tea'd it up!
You tea'd it up, girl!
(laughter)
- I didn't actually lick, Robert, I just!
Okay, sorry!